- Okay, so things haven't gone our way yet,
but we can turn it around.
It's a long road ahead, and
GOLLY, IT’S ALREADY THE QUARTER SEASON CARNIVAL.
- I want that prize.
- Josh, get in the tank
or we'll find someone who will.
- NEVER! JOSH DOBBS TO THE MOON!
- Yeah, lemme get one.
- Comin’ right up.
- Ugh!
- Total accident, dude.
- Woo, yeah.
- [Garrett Wilson:] We're just saying, Coach.
Maybe you don't ride with Zach this time?
- Guys, he's right here.
- Ow, it hurts my teeth.
-  Let's see. Can't ride with anyone too good
or I might upset Aaron.
Can't ride with anyone terrible or my locker-room will kill me.
Oh, my God. He's perfect.
- Coach?!
Coach!?
- [Announcer:] Attention.
Will whoever’s in charge of Kyle
Pitts, please report to the Lost and Found?
He's been here for, like, three years.
- AMANDA, AMBER, AMY...
Who did that?
- Sorry, Coach told me to throw the-
My comments
about coaching were misconstrued. I'm sorry-
Man, I can't win.
- [Bears Fan:] Yeah, that's the whole problem.
- On my count.
Hut, hut...HUT!
- He can't keep gettin’ away with it.
- Even though I know we're gonna fall...
- It's still a surprise every time.
Wait, where are you going?
- I'm not sure we ever drop.
- AHHH!
- Please stay seated for the duration of Tunnel of Love.
It ain't over until I say it is.
- I thought this ride was, like, supposed to be scary.
SMH I'm out.
- Oh, hell, yeah.
We're going Goff the rails, baby.
- Oh, no! I dropped it.
- But you held onto it for a long time though, pal.
- [Announcer:] Attention:
Please stop using the Giants’ line
as a turnstile.
Use the actual park entrance.
This is your minutely reminder
that Taylor Swift is here.
Okay, back to your little games.
Jonathan Taylor, please report to the Colts.
Nah, I'm good.